welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of
wanavision episode six
a terrifying halloween with juandus hex
warping the whole world into a creepy
clown maze
the weeknd could get lost in let's break
down this episode shot by shot for
all the visual clues in details that you
might have missed and just try to help
us figure out wanda the [ __ ] is going on
let's get started and again we gotta
start with the previously on segment it
calls back the real
mcu pietro's death from age of ultron
it's the first of many examples this
episode telling us that the evan peters
pietro is not
actually a recast as marvel has done
before but that this guy
is not pietro as the episode begins we
find ourselves in this early 2000s era
with graphics text punk music all
inspired by malcolm in the middle
[Music]
along with this trope of kids talking
directly to camera during the
introvisions newspaper has an
ad for westview appliances otherworldly
deals and a flying
saucer hovering overhead this reflects
the mentions of the lights visible over
west view in the newspaper last week
and vision's very first line in this
series my wife for the flying saucers
i see all of this as what vision was
intended to be by hayward
an appliance that he hoped to weaponize
against extraterrestrial threats
shifted away from manned missions and
refocused on robotics nanotech
ai sentient weapons like it says on the
door
the world's not the same as you left it
space is now full of unexpected threats
agnes has been added to the opening
credits wearing pants with
naughty and rhinestones on the butt now
agnes of course has always been
playfully naughty but even more in this
episode we are seeing her even greater
possibly villainous importance pietro
has also been added to the credits as
himself as if to say these others are
actors playing roles but this guy
is a celebrity guest star who's not
playing the part of pietro but just kind
of screwing around
as himself and who is that self you
probably know where i'm going but we'll
get there
the opening image of the episode depicts
a ghost and i actually think the alive
or dead status of these west view
residents
is now up for debate this halloween
billy wears a red cape and a
blue headband the wardrobe of wiccan in
the comics actually you'll notice
wanda vision pietro tommy they all match
their comics counterparts with their
halloween costumes the kids debate the
true meaning of halloween halloween's a
magical holiday all about family friends
and the thrill of getting to be someone
else for a day
wrong halloween's about candy and
scaring people but mostly candy yeah the
thrill of getting to be someone else for
a day kinda sounds like what this
mystery figure is doing as pietro he
looks false because this is
essentially a halloween costume version
of the real thing
tommy's milk carton reads maple hill
organic milk the way nature intended
from pasture-raised cows
definitely a step up from bova milk in
episode two
bova being the bovine genetic creation
of the high evolutionary who nursed
wanda and pietro in the comics
these boys play dance dance revolution
on floor mats
takes me back and of course my go-to
track smile dk's butterfly
you know it could be connected to those
baby mobile butterflies that want to
brought to life oh crap i'm becoming
that mean people keep tweeting me hey
by the way if you want to extend this
nerdy conversation you can join us on
new rockstars official discord server by
becoming a patron at patreon.com new
rockstars during this billy where's
these tiger slippers kind of like that
toy tiger we saw last week
no way they'd be able to hit the mat
since there's hard enough in slippers no
wonder why they're both miss
missing don't judge me this was my
primary cardio as a 12 year old pietro
snores on the couch but as boys talk
about them they use this great split
focus technique
it keeps pietro in focus in the
foreground while the boys talk and focus
in the background but keep your eye on
pietro
he is awake eyes open actively listening
but
continues to deceptively snore
you scared he's your uncle
why would i be scared and tommy says
it's four o'clock in the afternoon
you're secretly afraid he's a vampire
billy is a telepath sorcerer like his
mama so he's likely on to something
suspecting pietro's dark
supernatural nature because listen what
pietro playfully growls at them
blood is thicker than water meaning
family bonds are the strongest
notice how pietro tries to replace
vision as a father figure
big guy is a conflict twins need a
father figure for the night
don't sweat it sis i got the old xy
chromosome
yeah and pietro did not like vision
punching him in the shoulder there
and then after vision awkwardly kisses
wanda and then leaves
look at pietro's face there yeah these
daddies are
in competition now pietro mocks her
sakovian fortune teller costume
worse than the costumes mom made is the
year we got typhus
[Music]
whoa flashback to sokovia i love these
soviet era propaganda posters for rocket
science and nuclear energy
now you could say maybe pietro could be
dressed like nick fury wanda like black
widow but
i don't know when these people were kids
neither fury nor natasha would be widely
known
also halloween is not really celebrated
in eastern europe so
when wanda doesn't remember this it's
probably because it never happened now
it's a joke in the context of a sitcom
but it is a lie in the context of pietro
want a vision argue and billy tells us
mom and dad have been not fighting
just like different again look at pietro
he is looking over at him he can
perceive
past the context of the sitcom reality
because
pietro is not under wanda's hex wanda
even senses this notice how she
locks the door after vision leaves
something maybe that she felt like she
should have done to keep pietro out last
episode and it leads to
this
don't do that yeah pietro is not a
calming presence here he is
bad news he has a mom tattoo on his arm
some are saying this could be for
multiverse madness some people actually
thought it said h-o-m but no it is mom
how do i know because evan peters has
this tattoo already so can things that
already existed before the script was
written be easter eggs
sure so sword recovers the drone that
wanda threw at them and this is stamped
with stark industries
this is a piece of 80s weapon tech that
the company used to make before tony's
change of heart
and like that stark toaster it is
exactly the kind of stark hardware that
would have triggered wanda's memory
of that stark bombshell that never
exploded and traumatized her in pietro
hayward says
maximoff was never gonna negotiate with
us we take her out this whole nightmare
ends ah this is one of two mentions of
the word
nightmare this episode it's a pretty big
leap from giving people nightmares and
shooting red wiggly woos out here
the marvel demonic entity nightmare is
believed to be a possible villain of
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and possibly the big bad behind
all of westview here
i say possible but nightmare feeds off
of people as they sleep and as we saw
from wanda's exterior confrontation last
episode she
is not asleep during all this so i think
we can rule out nightmare just because
it's not as specific as those grim
reaper sightings or the devil stuff
hayward calls out monica's
insubordination constantly advocating on
behalf of super-powered individuals
yes i know your history with carol
danvers
and all you people who left still have
the luxury of optimism
yeah it's made to sound like it's
embarrassing to be associated with
captain marvel as if there was some
incident before the blip maybe some
incident that explains why fury was
reluctant to summon captain marvel every
other time earth was under attack
perhaps captain marvel was looked at as
a pariah for prioritizing all these
other worlds instead of tara c-53 earth
so then they go trick-or-treating
whoa unleash hell demon spawn
you know i keep bringing up mephisto but
this is why in the comics wanda's
children are actually revealed to be
pieces of mephisto's soul demon spawn
and as i've been saying these past seven
days since finding that gray corpse arm
in the mirror this ain't pietro this is
an imposter wearing a pietro halloween
costume
just with a bit of stunt casting by
marvel using a quicksilver from a
separate film franchise one division
might give us a multiverse might give us
mutants but this guy
is a red herring a pickled red herring
and now this mephisto has come to
reclaim these children born with wanda's
magic so he can reap the benefits
and he's doing it by wearing the
disguise of wanda's dead brother
wanda test samir what was the name of
that kid who was always trying to steal
your boots he had the skin thing
now you could see this as an odd to the
facial scarring of victor von doom
i don't know maybe in the mcu he might
hail from sokovia instead of leveria
i hope they do have liberia though i
like these fake places i love this in
the background there's a dude with a
jason mask and a freddy shirt he's
essentially a walking freddy versus
jason
nice this dude started the scene
chatting with the pirate in the jockey
but for the rest of the scene he just
kind of aimlessly stands by himself that
would be me i'm bad with conversations
though he is not as creepy as this hook
nosed figure behind wanda later now i
thought this was a mannequin
but look down there that is a human leg
this looks like someone pretending to be
a mannequin just waiting to pop out and
scare people but they never
do which is even scarier now pietro who
calls west view shangri-la maybe a nod
to the immortal himalayan refuge
founded by the vision of the comics but
maybe just used generally to refer to
james hilton's lost horizon for the
mythical tibetan kingdom
actually that mention of tibet is
interesting because i thought we're not
allowed to mention anything now piss off
china if tibet can be on disney
placement disco can be on disney plus my
friends but then they remember it's top
gun and another title if you listen
closely yeah kick ass
i feel the mean fuss me
kick ass so kick ass was a 2010
superhero movie in which
evan peters co-starred with aaron taylor
johnson and the way wanda says it it's
almost as if she remembers seeing those
two pietros in the movie now this is
weird herb reports back each of pietro's
vandalizations
before they happen all the canon has
disappeared
and then as some of the people get silly
strings they're frozen
it's like they're already glitching like
the people on the other side of town i'm
telling you pietro does not abide by the
rules of this hex
he is a virus in the machine wreaking
havoc herb asks
do you want something changed as we saw
in episode 3 herb seems to be a bit more
aware of what is going on in west view
let's keep an eye on it meanwhile vision
sees this woman stuck on a loop setting
up decoration behind her her partner is
also on a loop but
look at their motion they have each been
looped in post-production but at
different rhythms
you can actually see the dividing line
in the frame where that split screen was
layered in there but it still seems
unsettling because
they cgi'd in a shadow for the husband
that goes across that dividing line just
to make it all feel like it's part of
one shot even though there's no light on
him that would cast his kind of shadow
so that
plus this sad sad tear just makes all
this feel so unsettling letting us know
that something's inherently wrong here
but then this terrifying commercial for
yo magic yogurt now throughout these
episodes the commercials reflect a
different stage of wanda's trauma
and now this is wanda starving
emotionally alone in the void a
claymation depiction of what
wanda was trying to convey to pietro
later in the episode wanda needs her
magic to survive or else she will rot
into a corpse like her loved ones
so like a vulnerable child she keeps
trying to feed on this magic
even when that magic is brought to her
by a sharp-toothed outside predator
notice this little boy has already eaten
a fish earlier wanda threatened to turn
pietro into a pickled herring
and in the cutaway they were given what
a fish so maybe for wanda a single fish
could represent
that kind of line between starvation and
survival oh by the way you know that
credit card that you're afraid to look
at to see what the balance is
if you've been avoiding your debt it is
time to confront it upstart can help you
face it and finally pay it off
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple fixed monthly
payment upstart finds smarter rates with
trusted partners because they assess
more than just your credit score with a
five minute online rate check you can
see your rate up front for loans from 1
000 to 50 000
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit but also your income and
certain other information
provided in your loan application you
can get approved the same day
and receive funds as fast as one
business day so if debt is taking over
your life it is time to get a fresh
start with upstart find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com
new rockstars that's upstart.com new
rockstars don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent ya just go to
upstart.com
new rockstars the incredibles and the
parent trap play at the cinema
weird since one came out in 2004 the
other came out in 1998 they wouldn't be
in the movie theater at the same time
but this is kind of like the 2013 oz the
great and powerful plane in the 70s era
of west view the incredibles is about a
superhero family with powers taken
almost directly from the fantastic four
but here paralleling this superhero
family the maximoffs and the parent trap
is about
twins trying to trick their parents into
falling back in love maybe kind of the
way westview is
a parent trap for these parents of the
twins pietro tells wanda
i'm just trying to do my part okay come
to town unexpectedly create tension with
the brother-in-law stir up trouble with
the rugrats and ultimately give you
grief
he did just kind of declare his purpose
he wants to give
wanda the gift of grief why because i
think he feeds on her pain and then he
calls out her accent what happened to
your accent
what happened to yours yeah between
civil war and infinity war one
discipline accent just kind of went away
though it has started to come back this
will be your only
warning i think the lost accent and the
sitcoms are connected
wanda might have spent those two years
with vision on the run binging sitcoms
and she might have started
emulating the dialect of the character
she saw on screen and it was that time
that she is now trying to recreate in
this hex and then petro kinda explains
how he got here
i got shot like a chump in the street
for no reason at all and next thing i
know
i heard you calling me yeah he's really
kind of making fun of his own death in
age of ultron suggesting this evan
peters pietro is not
the quicksilver from the fox x-men
movies who would not know what aaron
taylor johnson pietro's dying moments
looked like but rather this might be
someone from this universe or beyond
this universe who
saw that death but is now okay with
mocking that heroic significance
who does that sound like to you so ellis
avenue is kind of the border they're not
allowed to go past
could be a nod to the mcu president
matthew ellis like maybe westview just
named the street after the president
matthew ellis was named after marvel
comics writer warren ellis
ellis could also be an odd to ellis
island where in the first x-men movie
world leaders gathered and were nearly
turned into mutants
from the nearby liberty island thanks to
magneto
her dad so we find out hayward is
tracking visions vibranium decay
remember vision's vibranium was fused
with living cellular tissue
so as that tissue decays it could cause
vibranium atoms in the cells to radiate
out we see four
circles in the bottom corner maybe those
are for the different types of radiation
maybe they're infinity stone related i
doubt it
not everything multicolored is infinity
stunt this one girl's costume
is probably the late rbg and vision
decides to revert to his avengers form
and he uses the mind stone to do it
interesting it looks as though the
further away people get from wanda and
the hex the less she's able to puppet
them
though notice even after vision reverts
he does keep his wedding ring
now vision does not remember his
avengers history because he exists as a
hex creation of wanda he's free from the
pain of everything that happened before
and that includes him just seeing
himself as a husband to wanda
but that manifestation does invoke his
soul that he had before that soul was
good and truth seeking
that's why he ends up questioning this
reality and is able to determine it's
false now you'll notice agnes license
plate reads
0 a 1 b 2 c which i did check this is
not the hex code for the color red i
don't know why people keep saying that
it's like a bluish black shade i think
it is significant because it does
alternate 0 1
2 abc and remember vision of one
discarded episode one was tagged
zero one zero two so it may reflect how
agnes by comparison
is literate in ways they aren't but of
course agnes is dressed as a witch
the latest smoking gun that this is
probably agatha harkness there's a lot
going on here that's weird while other
glitching residents cannot even talk
their frozen catatonic
agnes can and then after vision zaps are
awake
she still goes by the name agnes she
doesn't have an alternate identity it
seems like she is
more resistant to the hex maybe a
product of
it and that is why sword cannot identify
her notice how she clutches her chest
she feels around that's because
she's looking for her brooch if she is a
witch secretly serving mephisto
his soul could have previously been kept
in that brooch
that would be her husband ralph that she
won't shut up about the one who shares
an anniversary with her that's the same
date as the salem witch trials and then
maybe now that mephisto has taken human
form she just feels
lost without him and agnes says this am
i dead
no no why would you think that because
you
are because i'm dead
dead dead dead
it does kind of parallel that moment
back in episode three because we're all
white
what are you trying to tell me she came
here because we're all stop it
now in that moment herb might have been
about to say because we're all dead but
you know the id
wall does suggest herb is a still living
person it could be that there was some
inciting incident that
did kill these people in west view
before their deaths were reported and
that now their souls have been
resurrected
in the hex now that would pose some dark
implications for the
children now in west view did wanda
resurrect a bunch of dead kids to
populate west view
fittingly on all hallows eve the night
dead spirits walk the earth
monica gets a text from her mystery
engineer friend now editor john was able
to help me figure this one out take a
close look at that zoom in flip it i
think we can make out a five word text
i'm something hydra something something
something
maybe this engineer has some old hydra
tech that they're gonna use to make that
vehicle anyway for our theories on who
this person is check out this week's
episode of rogue theory i think we
covered all the options there so then
darcy tells monica
the energy inside has rewritten your
cells on a molecular level twice
it's changing you yes this implies
wanda's hex
might cause mutations on the dna level
in certain people perhaps
certain other people in the mcu were
born with genetic predispositions
that when they are hit with this hex
wave cause mutations to get activated
and that could be how we get mutants in
the mcu now moniker herself is clearly
being set up to become photon
but her lack of surprise that her blood
work and her reaction last week to the
doctor
suggests to me that monica might have
already been aware of her mutations so
then pietro asks wanda about how she
made west view handle the ethical
considerations of this scenario as best
you could
families and couples stay together most
personalities aren't far off on what's
underneath people got better jobs
you don't think it's wrong we kidding
i'm impressed
yeah pietro knows what these people were
like before the hex
to compare it now and he genuinely wants
to know where wanda got these kids from
maybe because he is mephisto and he had
to use pieces of his soul to construct
these two kids
and as we saw from agnes last episode
these two are straight up mystified by
wanda's ability to raise the dead even
if it is inside westview you can do that
then
so why does wanda see evan peters pietro
as a corpse the way she saw vision when
this pietro was not the one who died
well i think this pietro is warping
wanda's perception to further convince
her that he
is her brother because remember wanda
did not see pietro die
so he might feel like i can get in here
and trick her
i'm the one who died i'm your brother
forget how i look and sound a bit
different from who you remember your
brother to be because remember
as pietro said earlier his goal is to
give her
grief because grief enables gaslighting
now hayward's encrypted file is project
cataract and this codename could
correspond to vision as a cataract is
when a cloud forms on the
eye that decays one's vision
corpsvision's eyes are clouded over
as vision decays thus cataract now the
names james gad aka jimmy gadd and james
alexander
are marvel vfx artists we saw jimmy gatt
in the credits of the last episode
vision disintegrates as the hex pulls
him back in though the mind stone
remains intact i think this is because
vision's resurrection
came from wanda's powers which were
derived from the mind stone radiation
so as long as this hex is operational
and wanda is still alive
the projection of the mind stone in
vision's head remains though
vision himself apparently cannot survive
outside this hex and uh yes
vision's erosion is kind of like this
shirt this is our custom and unusual
couples shirt
it's filled with easter eggs that you
can only find via augmented reality
you can get this at
newrockstarsmerch.com and we are doing a
special sale this weekend for all you
lovers looking to get that special
someone a gift
10 off all new rockstars products just
use the code vision time day
new rockstarsmerch.com now in the town
square the movie projector screen is
showing george romero's knight of the
living dead
another possible clue showing us the way
wanda might be resurrecting the dead to
populate west view
pietro says it's not like your dead
husband can die twice another sign of
his
meta sentience because aaron taylor
johnson pietro died before vision
did how would he know that he was dead
but ironically vision did die twice
already once when wanda blew up the mind
stone and then again when thanos rewound
time to rip it out
and that first death that wanda still
feels super guilty over is probably what
trigger wanda's rage
she smashes pietro through these
gravestones one includes the name
janelle samelman who is an a.d for one
division she also worked on the
fantastic four
the epitaph though is a real detail it
says not
on her side which i think is a huge clue
point in the fact that pietro is not on
wanda's side
at all there's also rivas which you know
maybe pietros are kind of virus in west
view anagrams now one that freezes the
town and notice this happens precisely
united living dead when the walker is
breaking through the fence precisely as
walking dead vision is breaking through
the west view border and then
wanda's scarlet magic burst out
expanding the hex
expansion it sucks in the sword camp
including poor darcy
i love that christmas story edit there
something that confused the crap out of
me as a kid because i didn't understand
meta pov shifts something that
wandovision uses
liberally now the sword camp turns into
a circus
with the agents becoming clowns and
mimes see whereas within westview
everything was an archaic performative
tv show
outside everything becomes an even
earlier form of showbiz and escapism
a big circus tent and i love how one of
these mimes does the invisible wall
because she's now trapped behind an
invisible wall of westview herself the
truck turns into a funnel cake truck
funnel of love another reminder that
this whole hex was based on wanda's love
for vision
and the closing shot shows us wanda's
eyes as a scarlet glow fades
you can almost make out the shape of a
person in that red glow especially a
noticeable on the right eye
again i don't really think wanda is
doing this alone
some other entity is in the shadows
enabling her the true source of her
madness
oh by the way if you are interested in
what we do at new rockstars we and our
sister company social blue book
are hiring we're looking for a social
media manager we're including a link in
the description go check it out if you
want to apply we would love to bring you
on the team if you're qualified
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstar
subscribe to rockstars for all your
wanna vision questions thank you for
watching
boom
[Music]
you